[موسيقى]
قدم ابرز الاختراعات في عصر النهضه
للبشريه التي من دونها لم نكن لنعيش
التطور الحالي في المعموره
جورج ستيفنسون المهندس الانجليزي مخترع
اول سكه حديد في العالم
ولد في قريه ويلم نورث ببريطانيا في العام
1781 لاسره ذات دخل مادي ضعيف
فقر حالي اسره ستيفنسون لم يمنعه من تحقيق
طموحاته وابتكاراته فجسد قصه مثاليه
للانتقال من الفقر الى الثروه وبدا عمله
كمهندس ميكانيكي بسيط قبل ان يصبح من كبار
المخترعين ورجال الاعمال
تمكن من اختراع اول خط سكك حديديه في
العالم يستخدم القطارات البخاريه
كما اخترع القاطره البخاريه الاكثر شهره
في العالم والتي يطلق عليها اسم روكيت
وابتكر مقياس السكك الحديديه المعروف
حاليا باسم مقياس ستيفنسون واصبح مقياسا
عالميا لمعظم السكك الحديديه
اسس ستيفنسون وابنه روبرت شركه لسكك
الحديديه ويعود اليها الفضل في انشاء اول
خط سته حديد في العالم حيث وصل بين مدينتي
ليفربول ومانشستر والذي افتتح في العام
كما طور مصباح الامان لعمال المناجم مما
قلل بشكل كبير من خطر الانفجار في صناعه
التعدين
عد مؤرخون ستيفنسون مثالا للنجاح كما يضرب
به المثال حتى يومنا هذا في عدم الياس
وامكانيه البدء من الصفر للوصول الى
الاهداف
برياده ستيفنسون كان النقل بسكك الحديديه
احد اهم الابتكارات التكنولوجيه وعنصرا
اساسيا في الثوره الصناعيه
شيد له تمثال بمتحف السكه الحديد القومي
في يورك بريطانيا
توفي عام 1848
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات